hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play super amazing
wagon adventure turbo ok I put the call
out to you guys on Facebook yesterday to
tell me some crazy games you wanted me
to play and this was at the top of a lot
of people lists so here we go
start a wild at Benton between 1830 and
1870 nearly half a million Americans
migrated West okay I guess I wasn't done
or whatever man ok so I can ah here we
go
hang on first party member is Mark and
I'm pretty sure I'm a guy short black
hair kind of fits 2nd party member is
Bob who is a guy and he he has an
awesome beard and the last one is Wade
went pretty sure is a lady and he has
long brown hair Paul got it all good
that's cuz he's the [ __ ] in the
relationship they set off into the
forest oh this is lovely
I can't wait Oh what seeing some animals
in an upcoming clearing they hurried
ahead they needed to stock up on food
for the long trip well I guess I'm just
never gonna be done reading those mi
good god it's just a bow wow wow wait a
minute Oh skunks hurt you apparently
well I guess that makes sense why do I
have to murder all the squirrels I am
their King a posse abandoned oh ha ha do
I collect their bodies for meat as well
can I shoot their horses I can't
apparently yeah yeah get out of here you
bandits you don't wanna mess with my
wagon apparently that's a thing
Hey are you [ __ ] stop shooting at me
what is that
Wow what the what doesn't make any sense
at all
what time period is this I just saw a
jet go by I miss that power up why why
in the world who what why actually you
know what I'm not gonna ask any
questions about this because trying to
attempt to understand this James leaps
of logic is probably gonna send me into
a craze that I would never recover from
so instead I'm just gonna blindly accept
everything that goes on in this game
without question Oh God
get out here get out it whoa mark left
the wagon to look for wild berries what
why did I do that
do I shoot the berries okay you know
what
once again not gonna question the weduc
on his way back to the wagon marker -
noise and a bear wanted the berries oh
really mr. wait what his last dying
breath cry for rabid squirrels Oh No
aah squirrels I am your king don't kill
me I'm your king [ __ ] oh wait no I
wanted to click their bodies wait whoa
you could game you need to slow down for
a little bit
mark had the brilliant idea to try to
chip up at the river wall if it was my
idea it's bound to be brilliant right
they got a running started what wait I
guess somehow they made it a planted in
a den of bears
oh boy those bears are Dudley take a
couple bits ah I did Devon good god stop
it
Hey well you where are you hitting me
and Bob and not Wade oh this looks Pato
and Urdu God give me a second
could you give me a second Wade got
malaria about damn time
Jesus dead oh he's not dead they became
across a large herd of buffalo
Wow roasted boga no no no uh-oh just kid
don't kill Bob please go away don't kill
Bob anybody but Bob take me take me you
cruel game you bastard Buffalo buffalo
Buffalo buffalo Buffalo buffalo which is
a grammatically correct sentence
technically speaking but then
technically speaking a lot of things are
correct hey is that hell I don't think I
can get to that without hurting myself
chello Suki Chung I'm getting a lot of
Beefalo did you know that when the
people went out into the Wild West
they actually hunted the Buffalo to near
extinction it's a rocket launcher how
does that notice I guess I I guess we're
eating shredded Buffalo tonight the
number of Buffalo is absurd well you're
damn tootin well I guess we're eating
good tonight eh Bob what about me shut
up why'd you leave when we're good and
ready to let you eat you want you dead
of your malaria is he ever gonna get
better is he just gonna slowly die I
would prefer the bladder but I mean come
on weighing my options here what is that
it is that a laser gun once again I must
question the time period of which were
through huh huh some angry Buffalo aah
oh no not me oh wait he's got one elf up
not me not me to me go get me oh don't
kill me bro why he gotta be after me
yeah aah Oh aah Wade recovered from
mallero oh good I thought I was dead huh
oh wait as always out back
Oh where are you the first easier
smaller okay I guess you got a smaller
wagon now that's good I suppose they
path through a Civil War battle what
what it is help I'm a SAP no pumpkin a
dying several waiters full health what
kind of sick twisted world is this what
in the world is going on here I don't
know I don't care I keep saying that I'm
gonna stop questioning the logic of this
game but somehow in this sick twisted
world me and Bob everyone else and Wade
is at full frickin health what wagons
interference in the battles estimated
both the Union woman in a red dress
walking with Wade okay if this woman
doesn't miss her app was abandoned in
the sky what what what what oh good
murder way dead cuz you know what I'm
sick of Wade's ball and this game Wade
Wade gets the hell powerup of course
Grievous why not tell Wade kill him dead
kill him dead one shot from those Wade
and you'll be Jessa mated he's not dying
Wade one hmm
wait sang a song and cheered everyone up
maybe I shouldn't have been too hard on
Wade that guy's good guy way do you have
any bright at Bob at the brilliant idea
to swim under water through the river
okay that sounds crazy swimming our
wagon under water but I trust Bob
implicitly
they took a deep breath and jumped in oh
yes much better
let's just dump Oh God deadly piranhas
really good thing I got my laser gun
good God Oh No
ah choo choo there's too many of them
Stu ma'am the laser gun disintegrates
the bodies it doesn't even let me pick
them up afterwards but that I guess I'd
want to done angry angry narwhals with
the narwhal Bacon's at midnight ah what
is that oh is that a plane am I gonna do
that
air strikes thingy shoosh I made sense
no no I'm with it
I'm with it I'm totally with it and
poisonous jellyfish are the jellyfish
and oh god oh god oh god just eviscerate
everyone please if after all god that's
hardly fair why do they get to turn
around but they landed on a small island
to catch their breath
Bob no to some very large eggs sitting
on the beach and fancied an omelet for
breakfast no they're probably dinosaur
eggs or something don't do it Bob for
today put pterodactyls oh wow I called
that one ah I think I got a little Bob's
got a laser pistol don't mess with Bob
no you win oh no don't kill Bob oh don't
kill Bob Alan had an isolated ecosystem
in which dinosaurs never went extinct
Wow
did I call no get away from Bob get away
from Bob you sons of [ __ ]
good idea Bob well that's not a wagon
that's one of them Triceratops they
entered a mountain pass bond supplies
were dwindling so they hunted we hunted
you Ken
do we get to kill squirrels and goats
and deer in DINO sewers do we get to
kill everybody do we get to open the
door get on the floor everybody do the
dinosaur those look like little puppies
pack of oil smell the blood well I guess
it's a thing that's that actually is the
most pertinent leap of logic tick tick
oh come on they get to be behind me
laughs no no wait is left wait wait is
the only way died in a wolf attack okay
that's only fitting that's only fitting
well I think my sanity level has dropped
to extreme lows but other than that we
gotta go on a Wild West adventure filled
with Wonder and magic filled with
extreme things we're way too seduced it
survives as opposed to everyone else
dying wickets malaria but magically
makes a full recovery so I really look
here there's gonna be a fantastical
magic adventure where everything is
dreams and rainbows and nothing ever bad
happens and I'm gonna go myself in the
face with a bazooka how about that don't
see you in the next video maybe who
knows at this point
yeah you feel Barney oh yes back in my